a teenager named Abel Friedman and her
father have saved the bachelor mansion
from going up in flames
Wow et spoke with Ava via FaceTime to
hear about the brave teens harrowing
story oh my god and I went to our house
after we had evacuated to see if it was
still standing and there was fire
everywhere so we are on the road so we
weren't really sure and we got there and
Thank You Lee it was and there was no
active fire but we saw that the house
next door were they from The Bachelor
there was no fire and already some
damage to the property so we saw this as
not only a threat to our house but after
out to the rest of the property you know
so we wanted to get this fire out as
quickly as possible so we got our car
and we show up at this point there
wasn't really anyone on the roads
because people have already evacuated so
the only cars on the roads were police
cars and fire engines so we got our car
enemy try just to catch the attention of
a fire engine because our foxy line and
thankfully got the attention of a fire
truck and talked to them who said look
that house down the road or next door to
us there's a fire and we need to put it
out as soon as possible because it could
cause more damage and already has so
these great men and women went to the
fire as soon as we told them this and
thankfully they put it out and I'm just
really happy there wasn't more damage to
property or to my house so brave they're
so brave day before even lon
guys ET newsdesk brendan Jafra joins us
now red nails talked about it
did she from the videos it sounds like
she went to get help because she wanted
to do the right thing but do you think
she would get help also because it was
the bachelor mansion we actually asked
her about that and when we spoke about
it she said the first thing that came to
her mind was danger so she thought about
her neighborhood she thought about her
house which neighbors the property of
where the bachelor mansion is out there
in Malibu so again her first thought was
danger she imagined this entire
neighborhood that wasn't affected yet
going up in flames and when she saw this
she thought oh my gosh if I don't say
something if I don't get the attention
of firemen then this whole neighborhood
her whole neighborhood could have gone
up in flames but because she flagged the
fireman so quickly and they were able to
put out those flames there was only some
minor damage to that area like we've
seen the mansion for the most part
survived all right so what else did she
say about her experience Brendan we
heard a lot already but did she say
anything else to you specifically about
this experience because I could imagine
how kind of scary that could be for her
absolutely I'm we couldn't we kind of
touched on she had her walked me through
when we first jumped on this FaceTime
and we were talking I said just kind of
walk me through from beginning to end
what you saw and you heard of a lot of
it there in that interview and when I
first talked her on the foam and I
reached out to her to book her and say
we really want you to tell your story I
mean you did protect an entire
neighborhood your neighborhood here she
always kept going back to saying you
know it wasn't just the bachelor mansion
that she was trying to save that was her
entire neighborhood she was thinking of
her neighbor she's lived in this
neighborhood for five to six years with
her family again their property is
adjacent to the property where the
bachelor mansion just happens to be and
she was thinking of her neighbors the
whole time but when we spoke on the
phone before the interview happened
she was very back and forth on whether
or not she wanted his interview she was
really just focused on the fact that
everyone was okay the homes were okay
and her and her family have their home
to go back to such a strong sense of
community their brynan so impressive for
especially a young woman
so let's can we touch briefly though on
the bachelor mansion because for days
now there have been conflicting reports
of if the house is okay it's completely
obliterated what is the state of the
bachelor mansion as of today so I just
spoke with our producer Angela Jackson
who actually was in Malibu today with
our host Kevin Frazier and they had
walked through the mansion and I believe
he'll see more of that interview coming
up but when I spoke to her she had
mentioned that there was some the air
was a bit smoky in the room where they
shoot the rose ceremony when they're
filming the show she'd mentioned there
was some other parts of the property
that were damaged a storage facility
which caught on fire which I believe she
described as holding
pool supplies and stuff like that but as
we keep mentioning the main mansion on
the property where they really filmed
the show for the franchise luckily only
received some minor damage again being
the smokey rum Angelique had mentioned
to me that they believe maybe some
windows were open so that's why the
smoke came in she said they believe they
might have to do some repainting in the
house but again it's important to note
that this the main structure the main
building on the property did survive
well that's good to hear so even though
they're just what's the minor damage I
know some bachelor fans out there might
want to know is this going to derail
production for the new season of The
Bachelor
we have spoken to sources who tell us
it's not we understand that Colton who
is obviously the batch of this coming
season already filmed the scenes that he
needed to film at the property earlier
in the season and they're now filming at
other locations other remote locations
so luckily this shouldn't derail
production from what we understand and
everything is moving ahead as planned
with the show right well like I said
earlier ava is is a true heroine and
they're so thankful for her and I also
get a strong sense of community they're
bringing strong sands Lee absolutely and
I said her I said you know she because I
you know she had mentioned there and
you'd start at the top here that you
know she thanked the brave fire men and
women but I mean we have her and her
neighbors have her to thank too
because she really did prevent this from
possibly taking over her entire
neighborhood up there encourage more
loss sir Brendan thank you so much
always a pleasure thanks guys all right
well that's not all I'm Kevin Frazier
spoke Sam Marshall Hara Dean the owner
of the bachelor mansion about the
conflicting reports he received about
the state of his house a friend of mine
called me that lives out in the area
about two o'clock in the afternoon
sister just went by your house your
house is gone so you thought it was gone
I was gone and I just kind of sat down
on the floor and said hmm
because between the borderline stuff
going on and then this and then it's
just a lot of a lot at one time and then
I got another report about four and a
half five hours later from another
friend of mine Scott Eyre like down the
street and he went by and he looked at
it he said dude your front building is
gone here 4,000 square foot city is gone
and the rest of the house is untouched
so I'm going okay I need to see it for
myself Wow I could imagine the relief
that he feels you know some people went
home and they unfortunately didn't have
experience that he did once he got home
and saw that his house was still
standing so but also him thought you
know what he said it like it's been a
lot with the borderline shooting and
then this it's just just wrapping your
mind around all of that and then when
something hits so close to home how do
you how do you react what do you say
what do you do you you're it's not every
day that these things happen to people
personally so when this takes a seat at
the table what do you do I mean it
teaches you compassion and empathy for
others that go through it you know and I
think everyone goes to things for a
reason and maybe something personal in
his life it's teaching him something but
we never know but all I'm I'm just glad
that he's all right positive there is a
positive in everything but it's just we
just have to keep in mind all of the
people that did not have that experience
of going home and seeing their home
still standing yeah it's it's been a lot
for us um we've been covering this a lot
here at et live and again here at et
live we wish all the families everyone
impacted all the best you're in our
prayers and yeah we're sending strong
for you guys
[Music]
[Applause]